et dans nos talent c'est tout de suite
bonjour à tous édition spéciale de senna
360 en direct sur notre antenne consacré
la réforme des institutions
après la présentation du 1er volet
constitutionnel ce matin en conseil des
ministres la réponse de gérard larcher
n'a pas tardé le président du sénat
tient une conférence de presse vous
allez pouvoir l'entendre dans un instant
mais avant cela qui a t-il dans cette
réforme elle est divisée en trois textes
que nous détaille stéphane à valiant
première étape de la réforme la révision
de la constitution
le gouvernement a annoncé ce matin ce
qui devrait changer dans la loi
fondamentale de la vème république
parmi les mesures qui font consensus
figurent la suppression de la cour de
justice de la république
la transformation du conseil économique
social et environnemental mais aussi la
fin du statut de membre de droit au
conseil constitutionnel pour les anciens
chefs d'état ou encore la nomination de
tous les juges après avis conforme du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
mais d'autres points posent problème
notamment la mention de la spécificité
de la corse et surtout les modifications
de la procédure parlementaire le
gouvernement doit présenter deux autres
textes d'ici fin mai pour compléter la
réforme des institutions
d'abord un projet de loi organique qui
prévoit de réduire de 30% le nombre de
parlementaires mais aussi de mettre fin
au cumul des mandats dans le temps
limité à 3 successifs
enfin un projet de loi ordinaire sera
proposé il vise à instaurer une dose de
proportionnelle
15% des députés devraient être élus par
ce nouveau mode de scrutin dès 2022 et
dans le volet constitutionnel s'il ya
bien un point qui fâche c'est sony qui
concerne la fabrique de la loi le
gouvernement veut accélérer le travail
législatif pour le rendre plus efficace
sans relâche ses voisins
l'affaiblissement du parlement
explication jean marc blies c'est la
mesure qui rencontre le plus
d'opposition dont le projet de révision
constitutionnelle la volonté d'encadrer
le droit d'amendement des parlementaires
le projet gouvernemental prévoit
d'évincer des discussions tous les
amendements sans portée normative sans
lien direct avec le texte ou qui ne sont
pas du domaine de la loi
un encadrement défendu par la garde des
sceaux l'idée c'est pas d'affaiblir le
droit d'amendement mais au contraire
peut-être de construire un débat
parlementaire plus démocratique plus à
mieux adapté à la réalité
deuxième point de blocage pour le sénat
la volonté de diminuer le nombre
d'allers-retours entre les deux chambres
en donnant immédiatement le dernier mot
à l'assemblée nationale en cas de
désaccord finale en commission mixte
paritaire
alors qu'un nouvel examen dans les deux
chambres est actuellement nécessaire
autre mesure qui ne passent pas la
possibilité pour le gouvernement
d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour les projets
de lois les plus importants en
bousculant le calendrier parlementaire
ces textes seraient alors inscrit en
priorité à l'agenda des deux chambres
pour accélérer l'examen des textes seul
pourrait être débattu en séance les
points importants le reste étant votée
en commission
une mesure déjà mise en place au sénat
autant de mesures qui pourrait
bouleverser la procédure législative
mais sur lesquels députés et sénateurs
risque bien de s'opposer et je vous le
disais la réponse gérard larcher n'a pas
tardé à venir le président du sénat a
tenu une conférence de presse
on les coûts tout de suite bonjour
peut-être entendu
le gouvernement
posez en conseil des ministres son
projet de loi constitutionnelle c'est
l'aboutissement d'ailleurs d'un projet
annoncé par le président de la
république au congrès en juillet dernier
les assemblées ont accepté de répondre à
la demande du président de la république
en lui remettant leur contribution les
groupes de travail de l'assemblée
nationale du sénat ont émis des
propositions et le 24 janvier
je vous avais remis les 40 propositions
du groupe de travail du sénat
nous attendons les projets de texte
organique et ordinaire qui devait être
présentée ce matin qui finalement ne
seront le le 23 mai
si cette conférence de presse et ce
point presse est consacré aux textes
relatifs à la révision constitutionnelle
je répondrai bien sûr aux questions sur
les deux autres volets notamment le
droit électoral et la juste
représentation des territoires
mais les textes encore au conseil d'état
il faut naturellement regarder ça avec
la prudence et la distance nécessaire
devant le parlement réuni en congrès à
versailles le président de république
affirmé et je le cite qu'il n'est pas de
république forte sans institutions
puissantes il assuré par ailleurs que la
révision constitutionnelle ne pouvait
avoir et je le cite pour but de nourrir
cet anti parlementarisme ambiant
je ne pouvais qu'être d'accord avec ces
déclarations c'est pourquoi je me suis
toujours montrés ouverts à la révision
en y mettant notamment deux conditions
nous parlons de révision
constitutionnelle le respect des droits
du parlement et la juste représentation
des territoires
si les dispositions qui concernent la
cour de justice de la république
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
la présence des anciens présidents au
conseil constitutionnel ne présente pas
de difficultés majeures
je constate que le texte qui nous est
soumis ne correspond pas à l'esprit de
la déclaration du congrès et ce malgré
la lettre que j'ai adressée au président
de la république par courrier le 17
avril dernier
il ne correspond pas non plus à la
tonalité des échanges que j'entretiens
avec le gouvernement depuis le congrès
et qu'un certain nombre de responsables
de groupes politiques iep ici
entretiennent avec le gouvernement
au-delà des mesures à forte visibilité
qui ont focalisé l'attention
interdiction du cumul dans le temps
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
proportionnelle pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la vème république un
projet de révision constitutionnelle se
propose de faire régresser les droits du
parlement
il porte atteinte à des droits des
principes essentiels et par-delà à l'
équilibre des pouvoirs principe auxquels
je tiens à temps je pense au droit
d'amendement
à l'ordre du jour partagé et bien sûr
aux bicamérisme je crois pour ma part
de par mes convictions politiques
profondes à la nécessité d'un exécutif
fort
je crois aussi qu à parlement fort est
indispensable à un exécutif fort c'est
le fondement d'une démocratie
représentative et équilibrée elle non
respect de ce principe pourrait conduire
un déséquilibre démocratique et un
gouvernement qui ne soit pas attentifs à
la représentation nationale un
gouvernement qui ne soit pas canalisé
parce que c'est drôle du parlement dans
la production législative un
gouvernement qui soit moins soumis au
contrôle du parlement ce serait un
gouvernement qui fragiliserait en fait
la crédibilité de son action
préserver les pouvoirs du parlement
c'est préserver les fondements de la
démocratie représentative affaiblir le
parlement c'est risqué de déplacer le
débat dans la rue
quels sont donc les dispositions
proposées qui affaiblit cet équilibre
démocratique que je viens d'évoquer
monsieur peut paraître un peu technique
et pourtant il est fondamental
un parlementaire ne pourrait plus
déposer d'amendement sans lien direct
avec le texte examiné et ce dès la
première lecture
c'est l'article actuellement qui porte
le numéro 45 de la constitution et qui
est l'article 3 du projet de loi tel
qu'il vient d'être arrêté par le conseil
des ministres une telle règle briderait
de manière excessive nous semble-t-il le
droit d'amendement des parlementaires
et paradoxalement elle porterait
également une atteinte au droit
d'amendement du gouvernement qui dispose
aujourd'hui en première lecture d'un
instrument qui lui permet des
ajustements et des ajouts parfois utile
très vite il reviendrait à multiplier
les textes photos portant diverses
dispositions pour garder une marge de
manoeuvre
c'est exactement l'inversé de l'objectif
que je crois nous poursuivons tous
ensemble celui de l'efficacité des
procédures et de la qualité de la loire
je vais prendre deux exemples
si une telle règle avait existé
tout d'abord dans la loi relative à la
déontologie et aux droits et obligations
des fonctionnaires je parle de textes
récents à l'amendement du gouvernement
en première lecture avec un lien direct
a permis de visait à protéger l'identité
des membres des forces spéciales et des
membres des unités d'intervention
spécialisés dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
premier exemple deuxième exemple dans la
loire dit
pour la confiance dans l'action publique
un amendement du rapporteur du sénat a
posé la question du statut des
collaborateurs parlementaires et à
d'autres exemples je prends ces deux là
parce que une fois c'est le gouvernement
et une fois c'est tout simplement le
rapporteur de la commission
second point le gouvernement dans sa
proposition porte atteinte à ce qui fait
l'intérêt du bicamérisme et qu'on
appelle depuis toujours la navette
parlementaire
la navette qui permet de tisser la loi
c'est l'article 5 de son projet de loi
la navette est une des conditions de la
qualité de la loi
elle n'est pas du temps perdu son
objectif est de permettre
l'enrichissement des textes pour une
seconde lecture
je constate qu'en l'état de la rédaction
que le gouvernement d'ailleurs de la
rédaction d'aujourd'hui est très
satisfait de pouvoir compter sur la
lecture du sénat sur la réforme de la
sncf
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie aux propos du
premier ministre de 7 mai dernier et
j'aurais met d'ailleurs annoncé que
femme après midi contact avec deux
responsables syndicaux majeur parce que
naturellement c'est le rôle du parlement
de prendre en compte un certain nombre
de propositions auraient simplement
rappelé que depuis juin dernier
même dans des textes sur lequel nous
n'avons pas été d'accord
au total plus de 50% des amendements du
sénat se sont retrouvés dans la loi
c'est quand même qu'ils devaient être
utile selon la rédaction qui nous est
proposé les députés ne se prononcerait à
aucun moment de la procédure législative
sur le texte adopté par le sénat cas des
accords sauf sur les textes relatifs aux
collectivités territoriales il donnerait
en réalité les pouvoirs législatifs à la
seule assemblée nationale et à sa
majorité
on le fait majoritaire c'est ainsi
domine
mais les députés ne disposeraient alors
véritablement du droit d'amender qu'en
première lecture puisque l'orgue lecture
définitive aucun sujet nouveau ne
pourraient être amenées dans le débat
sans l'accord du gouvernement
vous voyez qu'on porte aussi atteinte au
droit d'amendement des députés dans le
cadre de la navette
conjugué à la restriction du droit
d'amendement dès la première lecture que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure cette
procédure ne peut être interprété
autrement que comme une forme de mise
sous tutelle des pouvoirs législatifs le
troisième sujet concerne l'ordre du jour
article 8 du projet de loi comme le
gouvernement je pense qu'il faut
examiner les problèmes que soulève
l'organisation de l'ordre du jour oui
sommes ouverts dans nos volleyeurs
débattu et françois de rugy avons
proposé des pistes pour une meilleure
organisation mais pas en sacrifiant le
principe de l'ordre du jour partagé qui
est d'ailleurs un acquis majeur d'une
révision de 2008
le projet de loi crée une nouvelle super
priorité gouvernementale est en fait
quand on additionne l'ensemble des
priorités c'est super priorité ça fait
90% des textes qui relève de la super
priorité
même le conseil d'état dans sa prudence
partage cette analyse
ce texte porterait atteinte également et
c'est ma responsabilité de président de
l'assemblée aux droits des groupes
minoritaires et d'opposition puisque le
temps dévolu à l'initiative
parlementaire serait en fait
considérablement réduit
de surcroît le texte proposé permettrait
démission du gouvernement dans les
semaines de contrôle
pour résumer on conditionne le droit
d'amendement
on vide son utilité la navette
parlementaire on préempte l'ordre du
jour je vois pas comment on peut nous
expliquer que ces dispositions vont pas
dans le sens de l'affaiblissement du
parlement bicaméral et de l'art
concentration du pouvoir
par l'exécutif nous invite à revoir la
dernière séquence de l'examen du projet
de loisy l'immigration débattu à
l'assemblée nationale pas un seul
amendement de l'opposition repris et
exclusion du groupe majoritaire du seul
député qui a osé voter contre le texte
ça promet bien sûr que la procédure
parlementaire doit être plus fluide bien
sûr qu'on peut et qu'on doit d'ailleurs
il travaillait au sénat nous avons déjà
engagé les réformes ni recevabilité
qu'on retrouve dans le texte au titre de
l'article 41
je rappelle que quand une disposition
proposée à caractère soient
réglementaires ou normatif le président
et elle est appliquée depuis plus de
trois ans parfois avec quelques
réactions d'une manière significative
de même la mise en oeuvre sans
concession de l'article 45 en une année
près de 310 amendements se sont vu
écarté de par cette procédure
de même nous avons engagé la suppression
des lois obsolètes et inutile dans une
opération qui porte un acronyme bureau
d'annulation des lois anciennes et
inutile alias ballet qui est en cours et
laquelle le bureau dans quelques
semaines aura une communication on peut
aller plus loin c'est le sens des
propositions que les deux assemblées en
formuler pour mieux faire la loi mais
aussi mieux contrôler le gouvernement
et je ne parlerai que du sénat il s'agit
de renforcer le contenu les études
d'impact souvent indigente
s'appuyer sur des moyens d'expertisé
indépendant d'ores et déjà le sénat a
prévu dans son budget 2010 9 des moyens
financiers pour des études indépendantes
des expertises que ce soit avec les
universités les grandes écoles ou des
cabinets spécialisés qu'il s'agit de
doter le parlement de saisir le juge
administratif
quand le gouvernement tarde oublie de
sortir les décrets d'application quand
il s'agit de renforcer le contrôle
parlementaire des nominations faites par
l'exécutif
nous avons également fait des
propositions qui concernent l'exécutif
obligation d'une composition paritaire
du gouvernement diminution du nombre de
ministres encadrement du recours aux
ordonnances cadrage du temps de parole
comme pour les parlementaires
ils tendent parole du gouvernement et
aussi comme pour les parlementaires
un cadrage du droit d'amendement c'était
d'ailleurs dans les propos du président
de la république lors du congrès à
versailles
au début du mois de juillet dernier
rationaliser la procédure ne doit pas
conduire à détériorer la qualité de la
loi ou à réduire les activités de
contrôle aujourd'hui à cette heure je
demeure ouvert à une réforme utile à la
france
le temps du débat parlementaire est
maintenant arrivé et le pouvoir
constituant appartient au parlement et à
lui seul
le débat qui s'engage démontrera que le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale sans
force de proposition pour faire évoluer
la constitution avec comme seul objectif
l'amélioration de la loi de la procédure
législative et du contrôle est en
quelque sorte un progrès démocratique y
compris dans la relation avec les
citoyens
mais ce ne sera jamais au détriment des
droits du parlement et de la démocratie
représentative et cela n'est pas
négociable
ça c'est clair c'est d'ici avant vos
éventuelles questions et je n'aborderai
aujourd'hui que les questions relatives
à la révision constitutionnelle et
institutionnelle aurait peut-être vous
dire un mot des avant projets de textes
ordinaire et organique
même s'ils sont toujours en cours
d'examen comme je le disais il faut sur
ce sujet avoir la distance nécessaire
je veux créer ces sujets à nouveau après
le conseil des ministres le 23 mai ses
textes sont essentiels pour le sénat
mais plus largement déterminant pour le
pays car ils touchent à l'équilibré des
territoires
et là aussi l équilibre des pouvoirs le
sénat je le rappelle ne s'inscrit pas
dans le fait majoritaire et ne répondent
pas aux mêmes logiques d'ailleurs
institutionnelles et électorales que
l'assemblée nationale
je ne vous renverrai pas au discours de
bayeux de 1946 mais c'est quand même là
que sont les fondements du bicamérisme
alors que le président et l'assemblée
sont élus et le gouvernement nommé en
quelques mois et pour une durée
identique lui le sénat est élu je le
rappelle par moitié à une période qui
est autre que l'élection présidentielle
pour un mandat de six ans et par un
électorat différents ce qui induit sa
singularité
c'est d'ailleurs cette singularité qui
lui permet de jouer un rôle
stabilisateur dans les institutions
d'être
contre pouvoir mais jamais un anti
pouvoir quels que soient les règles de
majorité les avant projets tels qu'ils
sont déposés remettent en cause
plusieurs éléments fondamentaux revient
d'abord sur un sujet qui m'est très cher
le territoire l'ancrage départemental
des sénateurs mais aujourd'hui garantis
dans la loi organique
les techs tels qu'ils sont déposés au
conseil d'état le rétrogradant loi
ordinaire
et pourtant le département c'est la clé
du maintien du lien avec les territoires
lors du non cumul qui soit clair je ne
doute pas que le sénat si pour ça que je
le renvoie la constitution proposera de
l'inscrire dans la constitution
le renouvellement partiel depuis la 3ème
république le sénat est renouvelée
partiellement pour garantir sa stabilité
son rôle modérateur
le gouvernement propose en l'état actuel
du texte de contrevenir à cette règle en
prévoyant un renouvellement intégral en
2000 ans et pour cela il modifie par
trois fois le calendrier des élections
sénatoriales mais c'est contraire à la
constitution qui prévoit un
renouvellement partiel
je renvoie aux articles 25 32 et 68 tirs
et 2 de la constitution et je vous
renvoie à une loi organique spécifique
au sénat qui précise à son article lots
de 176 du code électoral que le
renouvellement est partielle au titre de
la continuité d'ailleurs des
institutions cela dans l'hypothèse
s'ils perduraient ne serait pas
acceptable voilà mesdames et messieurs
au-delà de l'aspect constitutionnel ce
que je pouvais vous dire et je suis à
votre disposition et vous avez bien
compris je demeure ouvert à la condition
que ce ne soit pas inacceptable donc la
question se font les droits du parlement
et la représentation territoriale qui
pour moi sont essentiels nulle porte
n'est fermée
et encore faut-il dans la perspective de
la porte il y as par le mans fort une
institution forte pour un exécutif fort
je suis prêt à répondre à vos questions
sur ces sujets savez arg public sénat
sur le renouvellement intégral en 2021
du sénat vous venez de vous venez de le
dire à une telle décision ne serait pas
acceptable que comptez-vous faire
réellement pour vous y opposez qu'est ce
que vous proposez au gouvernement quel
calendrier peut-être non tout simplement
d'appliquer la constitution l'article 25
10 une loi organique fixe les conditions
dans lequel a lieu pour les députés le
renouvellement général et le
renouvellement partiel ou vous l'avez
dans vos fiches donc c'est pas des
sujets négociable porte des mois ou
alors on modifie la constitution mais ça
devra y tu avec l'aval du sénat
mais on poserait une atteinte très forte
à la notion de continuité de l'état et
on ne peut pas jouer avec ces choses là
on n'est pas dans un jeu n'est pas
attendu donnant donnant on est sur
quelque chose de fondamental par rapport
à nos institutions
bonjour isabelle fit sec pour les échos
comment vous expliquer alors que le
gouvernement propose ce renouvellement
intégral est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression qu'il a envie pardonnez moi
l'expression mais de se payer le sénat
et sa majorité actuelle ou est-ce que
c'est selon vous un élément de
négociation une menace un espèce de coup
de bluff
y a rien à négocier là dessus simplement
la préoccupation qui n'est pas
illégitime c'est le respect du principe
des proches inquiets
pour tout vous dire comme je suis pas
resté sans contact c'est un sujet que le
président de la commission des lois du
sénat a d'ailleurs prévu nous
permettrait que le moment venu quand il
lui a transmis le texte c'est à dire à
partir de la semaine prochaine mais il
ya des solutions parce que si la
préoccupation du gouvernement qui n'est
pas illégitime de l' équilibre des trois
cinquièmes
parce que je ne demande pas à des
placements des équilibres
institutionnels
je suis pour un bicamérisme inégale sauf
pour protéger la constitution et la
règle des 3 5e est une réalité
je ne demande pas qu'on la bouche c'est
très simple il existe des dispositifs
transitoires qui peuvent être mis dans
la constitution et qui permettent de
répondre à la règle des 3 5e
donc si l'intention est pure nous avons
la purification au travers d'un
amendement qui sera présenté au ces la
d'autres questions oui à génica limite
du parisien pour que les choses soient
plus claires plutôt que de prendre en
creux le la réforme est ce que vous
pouvez nous l'a donné en bosses cij pire
c'est hier sur quel point vous êtes
d'accord sur un certain nombre de petits
sites les 10 au début csm conseil
supérieur de la magistrature corps de
justice de la république conseil
constitutionnel d'aborder la question de
la différenciation territoriale avec la
réserve que nous pouvons avoir sur la
corse par exemple sur tous ces sujets là
nous sommes ouverts naturellement à la
discussion moderniser jeu par exemple
nous avons décidé avec le président de
rhji y quelques semaines d'examiner un
certain nombre de points pour faire
mieux la loi parce que c'est le sujet le
sujet sur les droits du parlement par
exemple s'est mis d'accord sur le
principe qu'il faudrait discuter en
navette comment on prépare mieux la loi
en amont avant d'ailleurs son dépôt au
parlement par une vraie planification
des travaux législatifs
nous allons proposer de soumettre le
gouvernement mêmes exigences que les
parlementaires dans la discussion de la
loi
nous avons aussi proposé de renforcer
les moyens de contrôle du parlement en
lui donnant la possibilité de placer des
administrations à sa disposition par
exemple la proposition de françois de
rugy prend stratégie mais aussi la
possibilité d'études extérieurs
ce que nous ne voulons pas que la
réduction du droit d'amendement
ce que nous ne voulons pas c'est une
navette qui soit vidée de sens ce que
nous ne voulons pas c'est interdit aux
parlementaires de déposer des
amendements et au gouvernement
d'ailleurs qui auraient un lien à dire
est que je vous ai donné deux exemples
on aurait bien d'autres
mais ça n'est pas cette institutionnels
nous nous sommes mis d'accord avec le
président de la république vous dire que
la proportionnelle me transporte pour
les députés serait un abus de langage
je suis favorable au scrutin majoritaire
mais nous sommes retrouvés autour du
thème de 15
la question du nombre elle est une
question de représentation du territoire
dans l'état du texte tel qu'il est au
conseil d'état met la tranche autour de
435 milles ça veut dire qu'un
département - 435 milles habitants n'y
aura qu'un seul député
je prends cet exemple est ce que vous
pensez
ce matin j'ai posé la question à un
département voisin se disait à
parlementaire il fait combien temps
département aujourd'hui à trois
parlementaires mdi 420 1000 mah si tu
seras tout seul et je pense que ça pose
une question de la proximité du citoyen
et que nous allons d'ailleurs d'autres
avaient proposé la réduction est compris
dans la concurrence comme on dit par
rapport à l'élection présidentielle y
compris des candidats qu'on a pu
soutenir les uns ou les autres
le sujet pour moi du nombre et de dire à
quel niveau on a une représentation
convenable et à quel niveau on permet la
représentation des territoires
deuxième des choses et le président de
la république
dans un échange avec moi m'avait dit
qu'il était prêt à examiner je ne doute
pas que ce sera examinée nous avions
déposé et philippe bas une proposition
de loi constitutionnelle qui a été
adopté par le sénat pour sortir dans le
cadre de la représentation des
territoires de la seule logique
démographique est un peu technique ce
qu'on appelle le tunnel des plus ou
moins 20% et donc de permettre que les
territoires soient représentés pas
simplement en fonction de critères
démographiques mais en fonction du
territoire qui le représente
tout en ayant moins la préoccupation que
les territoires les plus riches sur
démographie ne soit pas oubliée dans la
répartition
voilà pourquoi je ne fais pas du chiffre
244 un chiffre sacré gelé redit au
président de la république et je pense
que ce qui compte d'abord dans une
démocratie c'est de trouver le bon
équilibre entre la représentation des
citoyens un ou une élue et la
représentation des territoires ce qui
concerne le sénat oui vous aviez on nous
a volé le micro ouais parler il y avait
là pour désespérant oui et yannick fans
france info que répondez-vous aux corses
qu'il énonce une révision
constitutionnelle a minima vous qui
avait notamment plaidé pour une eau non
fragmentation de la république la même
chose je suis à chaque fois sur la
différenciation on s'interdit pas
d'examiner la situation insulaire de la
corse
mais en même temps une république
indivisible est une république où le
pouvoir d'adaptation parce que la
réforme de 2002 n'a pas fonctionné et
nous sommes sans doute en partie
responsable de ne jamais avoir écouté ce
que l'assemblée de corse demandé au
gouvernement et au parlement mais de le
faire sous le contrôle du parlement
oui bah vous voulez vraiment pas lui
donner le micro
ça doit être en plus pour une question
du texte alors allons-y
bonjour pour la route et au quotidien à
vous semblez en colère qu'est ce que ça
veut dire à quoi ça ressemble un marché
en colère et vous semblez considérer que
le texte est provisoire à vous écouter
vous dites est non négociable mais par
exemple le droit d'amendement a l'air
définitif ça a été présenté 13
officiellement ce matin en conseil des
ministres donc est ce que vous dites
clairement emilienne macro non vous
devrez passer par un référendum sur ce
point là merci je suis pas en colère
mais pas du tout que les airs suis
déterminé si vous la détermination et
des convictions fortes vous paraissent
de la colère alors mon image ronde il
faut la revoir
je suis déterminé sur les droits du
parlement et je suis certain que ça
dépasse tous les clivages ici politique
sur les droits du parlement
c'est en effet une affaire extrêmement
sérieuse
et pardonnez moi le sujet c'est pas de
manier ou non le référendum contre le
premier ministre était assez clair ce
matin celui de la france il s'agit du
fonctionnement de la démocratie
représentative
il s'agit de la relation entre les
citoyens et ceux qu'il mandate pour les
représenter et c'est donc un sujet
sérieux donc suis pas en colère mais
déterminé
n pascal reboulet afp est ce que vous
pensez et possible sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle d'arriver à a voté le
même texte que l'assemblée est ce que
vous pensez aboutir plus tôt à un texte
conforme et est ce que vous faites fi
nalement de l'ensemble des textes avec
le projet de loi organique et ordinaire
un paquet est-ce que c'est tout ou rien
voilà comment vous voyez les choses
le président de la république s'est
engagé à ce qu on est les textes les
trois textes en perspective c'est ce qui
nous a dit voilà pourquoi sur les textes
aujourd'hui à l'examen du conseil d'état
je n'ai pas eu qu une prudence de
langage j'attends de voir les textes
j'attends de voir les propositions du
gouvernement et
l'ensemble est un équilibre mais je le
dis sur les droits du parlement et le
territoire y a pas de négociation il ya
une discussion il ya un échange
c'est ce que nous allons avoir avec
l'assemblée nationale et je ne doute pas
que nous puissions avoir un dialogue
avec l'assemblée nationale j'ai si tu es
tout à l'heure en vous répondant
quelques-uns des points sur lequel nous
étions en train de travailler de
converger y aura naturellement partait
avec le même texte après la première
lecture
d'autant plus que je sens monter
d'autres sujets le sujet de la parité
d'ailleurs le sénat propose une parité
dans la constitution au gouvernement que
je sens d'autres sujets paritaire montée
je sens aussi parfois l'assemblée
nationale
les questions du climat vouloir être
déplacé de numéro il ya des sujets comme
ça et il y aura un dialogue
nous avons la chance ici je dois dire
que nous avons travaillé collectivement
tous les groupes politiques
et d'ailleurs je réunis la semaine
prochaine le groupe de travail pour
pouvoir examiner ce texte en mettant un
certain nombre d'autres éléments que
j'ai à transmettre plus personnellement
membres du groupe de travail mais aussi
en transmettant au président de la
commission des lois le texte d'avoir les
éléments de ce qui peut être la
construction collective du sénat pense
que sur les droits du parlement nous
aurons une construction assez
convergentes
je pense que si on la représentation du
territoire nous aurons une
représentation assez convergentes jorhat
autre point sur lequel il y aura des
différences il y aura des ajouts mais je
crois que
si les choses ne devaient pas aboutir la
responsabilité ne sera pas ici parce que
j'étais invité lundi qu'il ya cet
après-midi deux heures de débats que par
exemple le poids il ne croyait pas qu'il
ya d une surinterprétation affaire je
suis naturellement en liens assez
étroits
vous avez le président du groupe de
l'union centriste président des
indépendants le président du groupe des
républicains est là ce matin j'ai fait
le point avec leurs rapporteurs le futur
quelle méthode que le président de la
commission des lois avec le rapporteur
du groupe de travail et naturellement je
tiens à informer tous les groupes
politiques savez ici les choses sont
assez simples
charles gautier pour radio classique de
questions sur le renouvellement intégral
du sénat en 2021 la première c est ce
que le président ou l'exécutif ou qui
que ce soit du côté du gouvernement
vous l'avez clairement évoquée lors de
vos conversations et pardon la deuxième
est ce que j'ai bien compris que c'est
contre la constitution et que c'est là
dessus vous vous basez pour dire que
vous êtes contre est ce que vous y voyez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le dire
clairement une manipulation politique
merci je ne fais jamais d'accusation de
manipulation d'abord pour manipuler faut
qu'on soit manipulable et sur ce sujet
assez difficile non ce n'était pas dans
les sujets que nous avions discuté et
nous savons d'ailleurs que le
laboratoire qui a reçu commande n'a reçu
plus tardivement pour mon est entretenu
hier avec le premier ministre auprès de
l'arc de triomphe
je lui ai dit que ce serait un triomphe
limité si ça devait perdurer une on voit
la toile et il y avait d'autres oui
bonjour françois vignolle de
publicsenat.fr je reviens sur la baisse
du nombre de parlementaires avec 244
sénateurs il aurait quasiment un
département sur deux avec un seul
sénateur est ce que ça c'est acceptable
pour vous non alors faut arriver à
convaincre
voyez c'est bien pour ça que c'est le
seul point sur lequel nous n'étions pas
sortis des cas d'accord c'est pour ça
que l'utilisation de la référence de la
proposition de loi bas larcher c'est
rare qu'un président du sénat a déposé
une proposition de loi il ya maintenant
trois ans qui a été adopté par le sénat
à une très très large majorité est une
base de discussion pour trouver le bon
équilibre
oui bonjour canton vasselin sud radio
je vais tapper texte je suis désolé vous
avez dit lundi des cas la fin vous avez
voulu dire que le dialogue social sur la
sncf pourrait se poursuivre au sénat
pour améliorer le projet de loi qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire par là et
deuxièmement qu'est ce que vous pensez
plus à la demande et ce qui profite à
leurs j'avais rendez vous avec
téléphonique puis ensuite technique avec
un certain nombre de responsables
syndicaux
on va tout simplement faire ce que le
bicamérisme doit faire nous avons déjà
voté une proposition de loi déposée par
monsieur moreira porté par monsieur
gérard césar gérard cornu pardonnez moi
c'est le côté c'est à risque ils
emportent ou le bordeaux en tous les cas
donc nous allons jouer notre rôle
d'assemblée est d'ailleurs le premier
ministre a dit il faut qu'au texte au
sénat on puisse avancer or il a
sollicité le bicamérisme qui me semble
une réaction je partage du premier
ministre et je pense que c'est tout
simplement le fonctionnement naturel du
bicamérisme mais j'ai dit que c'était
pour la réforme de l'entreprise qu'ils
étaient pour la réforme de la
gouvernance de l'entreprise que j'étais
ouvert pour l'ouverture à la concurrence
on a déjà voté au sénat et que la
question du
statut des nouveaux entrants devait
faire l'objet d'une nouvelle convention
collective et que sur la question de la
dette
il fallait qu'on s'absorbe la teste
c'est pas tout à fait dans le texte dont
je vous m'avez fait un écart sauf que ça
montre l'intérêt du bicamérisme oui
dernière ceux qui n'ont pas posé de
questions encore temps d public sénat si
oui vous allez beaucoup du maintien de
la défense du bicamérisme vous pensez
qu'il ya vraiment des gens bien placés
qui souhaiteraient la fin du bicamérisme
à court ou moyen terme
on a l'impression que c'est toujours
régner c'est toujours une tentation
c'est surtout sur l'affaiblissement je
rappelle que ça a été une tentation il
ya longtemps il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça s'est su enfin longtemps il ya
une tentation c'est bartolone s'est
longtemps dit il ya une tentation 69 et
claude bartelone c'était un rêve un
damné
c'était un rêve mais qui n'est pas
devenu réalité non mais est-ce qu'à
d'autres personnes n'annonçant pas
relance de deux procès d'intention à
personne mais vous savez tout pouvoir a
besoin d'un contre-pouvoir mais il est
rare qu'ils le suicide d'une gaieté de
coeur absolu c'est vrai pour toutes les
sensibilités politiques
oui je retiens de fenêtres pas en
rondeur ça d'ailleurs très bonnes âmes
en fait n'est pas en rondeur du tout
est-ce que vous avez des contacts
directs avec le chef de l'état sur cette
question de la constitution
bien sûr et les quelques coups bien sûr
et je continuerai à en avoir
excusez moi je donne pas mon agenda sur
le sujet mais journée parce qu'il est
naturel que nous ayons un dialogue entre
le chef de l'état et moi même sur des
questions de cette nature
nous sommes aussi une république apaisée
une démocratie apaisée et donc j'ai des
contacts sur ce sujet avec le chef de
l'état
je vais pas vous dire le contraire
réponse oui bien merci à tous
voilà pour cette conférence de presse du
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
estime et bien que la réforme
constitutionnelle dont le premier volet
a été présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres est un affaiblissement du
parlement on va bien sûr en débattre
avec mes invités sur ce plateau
j'ai plaisir d'accueillir françois
patriat bonjour merci d'être avec nous
est le président du groupe la république
en marche ici au sénat sénateur de la
côte-d'or bienvenue à vous sur ce
plateau également hervé marseille
bonjour merci d'être là
vous êtes le président du groupe
centriste au sénat ce sénateur des
hauts-de-seine avec nous cyril belva
bonjour vous êtes sénateur et l'ère de
la haute savoie
vous êtes secrétaire de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable et puis pour nous
éclairer sur ce premier volet
constitutionnel dans un amour elle est
avec nous bonjour vous êtes un juriste
docteur en sciences politiques et à la
nes paris saclay première question pour
vous françois patriat puisqu'on a vu
gérard larcher qui se dit déterminé à
défendre les droits du parlement ils
font réellement en danger les droits du
parlement avec eux cette réforme
je crois qu'il faut mettre fin à une
forme de duplicité dans les propos entre
les propos engageant deux négociateurs
de discussion d'élaboration commun et la
position plus radicale au début et à la
fin du propos qu'il ya des lignes rouges
inacceptable crois que moi j'ai le
sentiment alors qu'il est qu'il ya une
volonté de la majorité
le mas otelli sénat de faire opposition
à cette réforme et d'y trouver chaque
jour un motif non pas de quels sont les
motifs
yat-il affaiblissement du parlement
j'imagine que mes collègues ses amis
vous m'expliquer pourquoi moi je
considère pas que d'affaiblissement
il regardera dans les détails y at il
une sous représentation des territoires
les territoires m'expliquer vraiment ce
que c'est je suis élu bourguignon mais
je représente pas les bruits je
représente les français au parlement et
le territoire n'a 2 alors que 6 jan et
s'il ya une représentation démographique
donc sur ces deux points je pense que
l'argumentation de gyan anarchie
aujourd'hui de dire ligne rouge
si aujourd'hui affaiblissement du
parlement et territoires sous
représentés on peut montrer qu'à travers
les textes en préparation et
ils sont en discussion en négociations
qui seront plus abouti après la
discussion au sénat et une marge de
manoeuvre intéressante
hervé marseille à quel est votre
sentiment est ce que vous pensez vous et
bien qu' il faut défendre les droits du
parlement qu'ils sont vraiment mis en
danger par cette ' réforme présentée ce
matin je crois que pas de radicalité
dans les propos je pense qu'il ya des
textes qui ont été présentés dans tous
les cas il y en a un
aujourd'hui qui a été présentée on en
annonce 2 la loi organique le projet de
l'organique et le projet doit simple le
23 mai qui ont leur importance parce que
la réforme c'est un tout il ya une
partie très constitutionnel mais on sait
aussi que ce qui concerne l'élection des
parlementaires
c'est quelque chose qui touche à la loi
organique et à la loi simple et il était
normal que tout soit mis sur la table et
le gouvernement a répondu à cette
attente en prévoyant de faire connaître
les trois textes sur ce premier texte
il ya des points sur lesquels je crois à
une très large majorité des sénateurs et
même des parlementaires en général
seront d'accord pour s'associer à la
démarche et sur d'autres il ya un
dialogue qui s'est engagée c'est vrai
que on peut s'interroger c'est pas blanc
ou noir c'est pas c'est à prendre ou à
laisser
je crois que il n'ya pas de radicalité
dans les observations qui sont faites
pas plus que dans celles qui sont
présentées je pense que sans chercher à
savoir s'il ya de la mauvaise foi de
part et d'autre il ya simplement des
propositions et c'est vrai que sur le
droit le droit d'amendement et un
certain nombre de sujets y compris pour
le gouvernement lui-même qui sont
interrogatif sur la cmp sont des sujets
très techniques
c'est justement du parlement je sais pas
si on peut appeler ça un affaiblissement
en tous les cas c'est des droits du
parlement qui sont discutées donc c'est
normal que il ya un débat qui s'engage
sur ce sujet un trek à jarlard s'est
estimé bien que l'esprit du congrès de
versailles n'avaient pas été respectés
par le président de la république on
écoute au-delà des mesures un forte
visibilité qui ont focalisé l'attention
interdiction du cumul de temps réduction
du nombre de parts
le mandataire proportionnelle pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république un projet de révision
constitutionnelle se propose de faire
régresser les droits du parlement
il porte atteinte à des droits des
principes essentiels et par-delà à l'
équilibre des pouvoirs principe auxquels
je t'y attends je pense au droit
d'amendement
à l'ordre du jour partagé et bien sûr
aux bicamérisme je crois pour ma part
de par mes convictions politiques
profondes à la nécessité d'un exécutif
fort
je crois aussi qu à parlement fort est
indispensable un exécutif fort voilà ci
rappelle var vient d'entendre le
président a dit senna ce que vous vous
êtes d'accord pour rendre cette
procédure parlementaire plus fier de
plus efficace
finalement je pense que en termes de les
parlementaires on est tous d'accord pour
qu'on a une procédure créée plus fluide
plus efficace par contre ce qui a été
rappelé aussi en mettant des lignes
rouges
et par rapport aux textes c'est que bien
évidemment nous ne voulons pas renier
sur les droits du parlement qui ont été
acquis et c'est donc de par là et c'est
aussi pour répondre à une des premières
questions qui ont été posées on voit
malgré tout qu'on assiste à un
affaiblissement du pouvoir du
gouvernement et par rapport à tous les
éléments qui ont été rappelés par par
gérard larcher notamment sur le droit
d'amendement
on va voir ce qui va en parler de la
commission mixte paritaire et aussi sur
l'agenda alors qu'elles ont de la sorte
a rejoint son plateau bonjour vous êtes
là sénateur socialiste du loiret vice
président de la commission des lois
le socialiste a travaillé sur cette
réforme va a fait ses propres
propositions sur la réforme
constitutionnelle est ce que vous vous
rejoignez gérard larcher dans l'analyse
avec la présenter aujourd'hui oui mais
je veux insister sur un point vous savez
moi j'aime le parlement et j'aime notre
travail qui consiste à écrire la loi la
loi il quand elle est votée elle dure
souvent très longtemps regardé la loi de
1901 sur les associations la loi de 1905
sur la séparation des églises et de
l'état
plus d'un siècle après elle
en vigueur donc nous nous devons veiller
à ce que chaque ligne chaque mot de la
loi soit juste parce que ça va
s'appliquer à tous les français et c'est
pourquoi je ne partage pas ce discours
perpétuel où on nous dit il faut aller
vite faut aller plus vite il faut vers
les lois très vite mais non le temps de
la loi c'est pas le temps de l'actualité
ce n'est pas nouveau en pierre sfeir
françois hollande lui même aussi c'était
blindé certaine lenteur du parlement et
je n'étais pas d'accord non plus car eux
voyez vous depuis eu un an mais ç'a
commencé avant la plupart des lois
eux-mêmes toutes les lois sont présentés
selon la procédure d'urgence
or la procédure d'urgence dans la
constitution
elle a toujours été considérée comme
exceptionnelle et moi j'enrage
quelquefois qu'il y ait une lecture au
sénat une l'assemblée terminée mais non
il faut du temps
sinon il arrive que les lois soient mal
faite et qu'on doive tout recommencer
donc moi moi je dis mais faisons prenons
au sérieux
l'amour de la loi vous comprenez la loi
je vais prendre un exemple
c'est comme un rocher vous savez qui est
un galet qui est poli par la marée il
faut l'améliorer et donc il faut le
temps il faut pas que ça dure une
éternité
et moi j'ai plein d'idées pour que l'on
soit plus efficace
la réponse du premier conseil des
ministres ce matin et bien encore
philippe bacquet nicolas beloou b ont
tenu une conférence de presse il a tenu
à rassurer justement sur cette question
de l' équilibre entre les pouvoirs
législatif et exécutif
on écoute le premier ministre notre
objectif encore une fois et de revenir
d'une certaine façon à l'esprit de la
vème république
il n'est donc évidemment ni d'abaisser
certains ni d'élever d'autres il s'agit
d'avoir une forme de
efficacité réciproque entre le parlement
et le gouvernement
nous devons travailler ensemble et la
qualité de notre travail collectif qui
sert la démocratie n'a d'intérêt que si
ce travail est efficace et l'objectif de
ce texte c'est de faire en sorte que
notre travail en commun soient plus
efficaces plus rapides quand c'est
nécessaire
pas forcément à chaque fois mais plus
rapide quand c'est nécessaire
et peut-être aussi plus concentrés sur
les sujets qui relèvent pleinement d'un
débat public est intense pour écarter
les éléments qui eux peuvent être
traitées autrement soit en commission on
l'a vu soit qu'ils ne relèvent pas
directement du débat législatif
personnes à montréal sans surprise on
voit que ce premier volet on ne passe
pas auprès du sénat est ce que à les
mesures contenues porte réellement
atteinte à cet équilibre dont je parlais
entre le pouvoir exécutif d'un côté le
pouvoir législatif de l'autre et au delà
et bien atteint tomic améris mme bah ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
quand le premier ministre dit retour à
l'esprit de la vème république
l'objectif de la vème république
originellement c'est de mettre tout en
place pour avoir un parlement cadenassé
un parlement à la botte du gouvernement
et du président de la république
alors depuis cette origine de la vème
république on a eu des réformes
successives pour donner un peu de
pouvoirs au parlement
le point d'orgue étant la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008
là on a une réforme qui d'une certaine
façon est bien en effet revient sur un
actif sûr quelques acquis qui ont été
portées en 2008 et même va plus loin que
ce qu'il y avait avant en terme de droit
d'amendement en termes de navettes
parlementaires
donc tout ça pose quand même un certain
nombre de questions parce qu'on a déjà
des institutions qui sont très
déséquilibrée de tous les parlements du
monde occidental
le parlement français est probablement
l'un des plus faibles l'un qui a le
moins de pouvoir et le moins de force de
contrôle de propositions sanary nawak le
bundestag
ça n'a rien à voir avec la chambre des
communes dire eh bien pour rationaliser
on va encore un peu plus serré les vis
c'est une forme de face en tout cas ça
pose question
j'aimerais revenir un petit peu sur ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure par jean
pierre sueur sur le temps le vote moyen
d'une loi en france ses 149 jours en
allemagne c'est sans que ces 156 jours
en pays bas c'est 400 donc on est en
foot il faut tourner dans la moyenne
on a à peu près on en à peu près dans la
moyenne là dessus donc on est à peu près
dans la moyenne sur le temps d'examen
pour noah si on vous regarde les
parlements qui vont plus vite que nous
c'est soit des pays monocaméral soit des
pays relativement autoritaire la palme
et ben justement à laon la hongrie
qu'elle met 30 jours françois patriat
alors j'aime bien car le mans je suis
comme mon ami jean-pierre sueur mais
j'aime bien à parlement qui est utile et
pas par le manque et la maison des
palabres
si le gage de la qualité d'une loi
c'est le temps qu'on met pour le
discuter art petit parra petit élément
par élément virgules
père virgules alors je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'on arrive dans un exemple
on perd la loi nôtre on a dû voir dix
fois on a dû y passer trois mois
c'est la pire loi qu'on ait jamais connu
je pense que la pire loi qu'on ait
jamais connu et qu'aujourd'hui elle est
contestée par tous les élus jeunes de la
république
voilà le voit sur laquelle on a passé du
temps dans les vingt deux diamants en
quoi le pouvoir du parlement et il
affaiblit le fait qu'on ne veuille pas
discuté de ma d'amendements sans rapport
avec le texte
en quoi est-ce que ça affaiblit le
parlement demain d'éliminer des
amendements qui n'ont rien à voir avec
le texte
en quoi le parlement et il a faibli
parce qu'une fois qu'on a eu une
commission mixte paritaire
il y aura une lectures dans les deux
assemblées ou d'avoir trois ou quatre
lectures derrière à quoi ça servira je
pense que l'on voit bien ici nous vivons
ici des heures et des heures de séance
de jour et de nuit
nous on voit donc on pourrait non pas
les économiser nous parle qu elle lui
tend le cou pourrait mieux travailler
tout en plus que le parlement est
parfois redondants je vois qu'on examine
une loi sur la sncf pendant une semaine
un demande monsieur morin chers amis et
vous sur la loi alors on va discuter de
l'asn de la loi et sierre donc tout sera
dedans
dans trois semaines au sénat est-ce
qu'on n'a pas perdu un peu de temps donc
le bling et que le fait que le
gouvernement veut il mettre à l'ordre du
jour des textes de loi qui lui
paraissent essentiels si on veut
vraiment changer les choses si on veut
que les réformes servent à quelque chose
qu'elles changent le quotidien des
français je pars convaincu qu'il fallut
mettre autant quand vous donnez la
parole monsieur puisqu'on parle du droit
d'amendement je vous propose d'écouter
gérard larcher puisque le droit
d'amendement c'est finalement la raison
d'être du parlementaire écouter ce qu'on
a dit le président assad à tout à
l'heure
une telle règle briderait de manière
excessive nous semble-t-il le droit
d'amendement des parlementaires
et paradoxalement elle porterait
également une atteinte au droit
d'amendement du gouvernement qui dispose
aujourd'hui en première lecture d'un
instrument qui lui permet des
ajustements et des ajouts parfois utile
très vite il reviendrait à multiplier
les texte fourre-tout portant diverses
dispositions pour garder une marge de
manoeuvre
c'est exactement l'inversé de l'objectif
que je crois nous poursuivons tous
ensemble celui de l'efficacité des
procédures et de la qualité de la loire
est ce que le gouvernement a déterré la
hache de guerre avec cette question du
tri strict des amendements hervé
marseille je sais pas je voudrais juste
un mot sur le débat qui vient de nos
échanges du moins qui vient d'avoir lieu
entre françois patriat et aux
collectionneurs
je dirai ce que le gouvernement s'engage
à faire des décrets d'application dans
les mêmes délais parce que moi je veux
bien qu'on fasse des techs plus vite
tout le monde est d'accord mais souvent
il faut attendre un an avant d'avoir les
décrets d'application tous les décrets
de la loi travail sont aujourd'hui
signée elle a été votée pendant le mois
d'août
mais françois lemieux vous dire
simplement c'est aussi la question parce
qu'on voit pas bien dans tout ça on nous
a dit moins de parlementaires et tous
les candidats aux présidentielles
soyons clairs ont tous proposé moins de
parlementaires donc sur le sujet je
crois qu'il ya plus ou moins à un quasi
consensus sera toujours à savoir la
caisse on n'arrête pas après c'est la
question de la répartition mais avec
quels moyens et quel objectif parce que
l'idée c'est quand même d'avoir moins de
parlementaires bon le problème de la
représentation territoriale
et puis il ya surtout qu'est ce qu'on
leur donne pour mieux contrôler l'action
du gouvernement quelle responsabilité
quels pouvoirs
on peut donner à ces parlementaires pour
qu'ils exercent leurs responsabilités de
façon un peu plus forte 5 alba pardon
sur ce point je n'en a pas relancer de
grands classeurs sur les amendements que
vous avez tous connus ici effectivement
des amendements discutés en commission
réseauter et de nouveaux retravaillé
conseillons c'est faut peut-être
réfléchir à à une accélération justement
du temps sur ce point de les abandonner
voilà déjà je voulais revenir un peu sur
le sur les discours d'edouard philippe
deux premiers ministres ont aidé il faut
qu'on travaille plus avec le parlement
sauf que dans les textes qui sont
arrivés notamment la réforme
constitutionnelle
il ya des éléments qui sont sortis qui
était pas du tout discuté en amont donc
quelque part est un peu un mépris du
travail de parlementaires des
propositions qu'on pu être faite par
l'intégralité des groupes politiques ici
présents à presse les amendements je
rejoue a bien évidemment ce qu'a dit le
président larcher en coton et rapporteur
du texte
bien souvent on se retrouve en fin de
séance et en 2e ou 3e ou enfin en
deuxième lecture notamment avec des
abonnements qui viennent de gouverner
moi j'ai le cas dans le cas de la
montagne avec des financements sur lyon
turin et d'autres sur le médecin de
campagne et je trouve effectivement
qu'avec ce qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui bien sûr il faudra affiner
et c est aller plus loin et le travail
parlementaire il travaille vava va aller
dans ce sens là on empêche les
parlementaires et aussi le gouvernement
de pouvoir déposer des amendements donc
maintenant est ce qu'il faut aller plus
vite ça je sais pas mais en tout cas
mais sur le sur l'aspect amendement il
faut qu'on ait le droit de pouvoir les
déposer systématiquement parce qu'on
voit aussi que des fois l'actualité va
très vite et on donne besoin de pouvoir
aussi ajuster dans le cadre des textes
et le risque d'avoir un texte très très
large fourre tout qui est tel qu'il est
tel qu'il est mentionné à mon avis est
une réalité sur le travail au quotidien
il faut limiter le nombre d'amendements
jean pierre serre mais non c'est vous
savez pour les parlementaires le
l'amendement c'est comme l'air qu'on
respire cher delphine girard cher
françois
nous avons vécu toi et moi environ dix
ans à l'assemblée nationale une dizaine
d'années au sénat 18 ans ou 18 ans très
bien bravo vacher vue je monte but mais
pendant lesquelles on ne nous a jamais
jamais parlé de l'article 41 de la
constitution de l'article 45
aujourd'hui on nous dit je vais prendre
un exemple très concret oui vous je suis
en contact avec les associations des
victimes des attentats qui veulent qu'on
puisse gérer traités dignement les
restes humains à la suite de ses
malheurs
il faut un amendement qui dure une ligne
je le présente dans une loi sur
l'égalité citoyenneté on me dit c'est
hors sujet on me dit actu ac a présenté
une proposition de loi vient arrivera
jamais donc il faut arrêter cette espèce
d'intégrisme sur les amendements qu'on
soit libre de présenter les amendements
et puis après c'est le parlement qui
vote la loi
si le parlement pense que c'est hors
sujet mais votre acompte mais que cette
histoire de commission n'était qu'avec
une laize instamment la non non ça va
pas y aura juge de paix gouvernementale
qui nous interdira mais non il faut être
libre il faut qu'on soit bien dans nos
baskets et françois tu es tellement bien
dans ses baskets
je suis sûr
des amendements il ya plus il ya deux
grands aspects sur cette question des
amendements il ya la question d
irrecevabilité ce dont on a surtout
parlé qui vise à dire eh bien tout ce
qui n'a aucun lien direct et j'insiste
bien sur le direct parce qu'on a quelque
chose qui est plus fort aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est le conseil qu'elle
juge de paix et il exige qu'il n'y ait
pas de lien qu'ils soient trop indirects
donc là on durcit donc il faut qu'il y
ait un lien direct avec le texte ce qui
en effet pose une question en termes
d'initiatives de chaque parlementaire
est où il est il faut qu'il y ait une
portée normative que ce soit parce qu'on
appelle des neutrons législatif qui est
derrière est bien quelque chose qui soit
réellement applicable
le problème c'est que ces deux idées en
fait elles sont très larges elles sont
très floues la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel est pas évidente faire
passer ça dans la constitution et faire
du gouvernement le juge de paix parce
que certes il ya un recours devant le
conseil constitutionnel qui est possible
mais il faut quand même que le président
de l'assemblée à ce moment-là accepte de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
notamment pour l'assemblée nationale ces
problématiques
donc là il ya quand même un risque de
réduction du nombre des amendements dans
les deux du nombre de la portée du droit
d'amendement
dans les faits donc là il ya quelque
chose qui est tout de même ambiguë
dangereux parce que les femmes sont
ambigus le deuxième aspect c'est est ce
qu'on peut présenter deux fois le même
amendement en commission et en séance
publique jus et là il ya un certain
nombre de questions qui peuvent se poser
si on décide que seuls les amendements
examinés n'ont examiné en commission
peuvent être déposés en ce sens public
foulée tous les parlementaires sont pas
présents en commission et un
parlementaire qui décide de déposer un
amendement en commission qui n'est pas
adopter s'il changer une virgule est ce
que sont quand même amendement là encore
on est dans quelque chose de flou par
ailleurs c'est un peu une prime au crime
c'est à dire que si vous êtes
parlementaire si vous jugez que votre
amendement ne va pas être adoptés en
commission ou que vous voulez réellement
en revendiquer la paternité
eh bien vous le déposez plus tôt en
séance publique et donc on surcharge la
séance publique où et on vit de
l'intérêt de l'examen en commission dans
la révision de 2008
donc là il ya de fausses bonnes idées
sur tous ces aspects je pense france
appelle moi j'aime bien les expressions
des opérateurs
ni l'amendement c'est à dire qu'on
respire ça peut être aussi l'oxydé de
carbone qui as écris parce que dans les
époques que tu as évoqué je me souviens
des lois de décentralisation sous de
faire trois mille amendements y compris
un amendement de monsieur toubon qui est
l amendement des cocotiers pour résoudre
les problèmes de la population il
fallait faire comme en afrique faire
monter les vieilles huiles cocotiers
secoué comme ça il y en aurait moins
j'ai vu ça comme amendement j'attends
justement devant là je point un texte
plus récents voilà que le texte de loi
hd mentation veut arriver à l'assemblée
déjà plus de 2200 amendements déposés
comme dit un grand parlementaire dudi
sela foire à la saucisse madame nathalie
aussi retrouve plus on parle de tout de
n'importe quoi tout le monde en rajoute
tous les lobbys viennent autour c'est
même plus possible de discuter de
l'essentiel du texte
je crois qu'il faut être beaucoup plus à
l'est est irrationnel il ya un texte de
loi il est amendable
c'est le c'est le parlement qui fait la
loi qu'il le fasse dans des conditions
bien le dire un peu décente et qu'on ne
discute pas pendant des heures entières
les sourds est que nous passons en
séance pour avoir un amendement nous
arrivons au même amendement discussion
commune 10 amendements dits prise de
parole à l'ewi jean s'écoute parler
c'est vraiment la maison des malades
c'est pas la maison de la démocratie ne
s'use que si l'on ne s'en sert pas alors
tu as raison à jacques toubon est
l'exemple vivant du fait qu'on peut
avoir deux vies je me rappelle quand
jacques toubon était un opposant
extraordinaire mais je voulais ajouter
un autre point cher delphine girard
c'est que il ya autre chose qui pose
vraiment problème vous savez qu'en 2008
on a obtenu c'était nicolas
si vous parlez de l'ordre du jour enfin
on va y venir chercher dans un instant
on prend les traits vous faire écouter
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux qui
a également réagi à cette question est
bien de l'accélération des travail
parlementaire c'était ce matin l écoute
écoute et nicole belloubet dans un
instant la garde des sceaux qui est
revenu sur cette question du temps
resserré on écoute il est également
proposé troisième mesure de réduire le
nombre de discussions qui peuvent
s'élever aujourd'hui jusqu'à 13
discussions quand on considère les
commissions les séances et c est dans
les deux chambres
et donc nous proposons qu'après l'échec
d'une commission mixte paritaire le
dernier mot puisse être donné comme
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale mais
dans des conditions plus resserrée
rupture j'ai parlé à l'aise là vraiment
c'est grave mais non mais c'est
gravissime
ou bien on est pour le bicamérisme on
n'est pas pour le bicamérisme miral est
sûre on à la mairie sme
il faut que l'on puisse avoir après la
commission mixte paritaire
une lecture à l'assemblée et une lecture
au sénat puis l'assemblée a le dernier
mot
c'est tout à fait mais c'est tout à fait
logique alors d'autre part par rapport
aux amendements
est ce que vous pouvez me citer dans les
30 ou 40 dernières années un seul test
dont le gouvernement en place voulait
qu'ils passent et qui en raison du
nombre d'amendements n'a pas pu passer
il n'y a pas d'exemple c'est à dire
qu'il ya eu des textes eu beaucoup
d'amendements mais finalement ces textes
ont été adoptés et où il n'ya pas de
temps programmé je suis résolument
contre
et eux il n'ya pas d'obstruction et bon
ben il ya des textes qui donnerait des
débats passionnés mais c'est la
république un besoin peut-être aussi des
français de voir des réformes adoptées
rapidement
oui mais encore une fois il faut
s'entendre sur ce que c'est rapidement
alors sur le temps législatif programmé
sur le cas j'aimerais quand même revenir
on a là un incomplète pour on pète
contre mon alain instrument fort qui
fait qu'on fait il ya plus réellement
d'obstruction donc depuis la réforme de
aujourd'hui le gouvernement ou les
présidents d'assemblée ont tous les
éléments
dans les mains pour éviter les grands
phénomènes d'obstruction parliez des
amendements cocotiers on peut également
se souvenir de la loi sur edf de la loi
sur l'annexé ces situations-là ces
circonstances là qu'on avait connue
surtout au début des années 2000 à la
fin des années 90 aujourd'hui on a les
instruments pour lutter contre alors
après les français veulent peut être
avoir des lois plus vite mais pour
qu'une loi soit rapidement adoptée et
pour qu'elle soit on va dire bien
adopter il faut tout de même qu'elle
soit de qualité c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on les pensait il faut qu'on les
corrige et y compris sur des questions
de forme
et tout ça ça prend du temps parce que
si on prend pas ce temps là qu'est ce
qui se passe
eh bien d'abord comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure les décrets d'application
mais très longtemps apparaître la loi
travail la loi travail qu'on a voté en
urgence et qui a suscité quand même de
ddd balourd
elle a mis environ trois mois trois
quatre mois être adopté
les décrets d'application les derniers
ils sont parus emmanuel macron été
prises dans la république
donc on a un vrai décalage de temps
entre d'un côté un temps qui devrait
être rapide au parlement est une
application des lois qui dépend du
gouvernement qui lui généralement prend
son temps pour qu'une loi soit
réellement applicable pour qu'une noix
sous réellement démocratique également
c'est à dire qu'elle elle elle soit ce
que les parlementaires les représentants
du peuple en ont pensé
il faut qu'elle soit bien écrite si elle
n'est pas bien écrite et bien ça donne
du pouvoir à qui ça donne du justement
du pouvoir à ceux qui écrivent les
décrets et au juge qui ensuite se
retrouve avec des lois inapplicables
donc ça donne ça débouche sur un le
gouvernement des juges et 2 le pouvoir
de la technocratie donc le temps qui est
passé au parlement à faire de bonnes
lois c'est pas un temps excessif par
rapport au temps qu'on met pour les
appliquer et c'est sur tendue c'est
surtout du temps nécessaire pour que ces
lois justement rentrer rapidement et
bien en application alors on va
continuer cette analyse en plateau mais
vous savez ces principes de cette
émission on va retrouver est en train de
nuit a depuis la salle à des conférences
et exhaustive le comte sénateurs
socialistes qui représentent les
français de l'étranger c'est tabou oui
jean yves le conte est ce que vous
estimez à l'image de gérard larcher qu'à
travers et bien le projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui a été dévoilée ce
matin il ya une véritable régression des
droits du parlement
c'est une régression démocratique c'est
une progression de l'autoritarisme de
l'exécutif c'est pas juste une
régression des droits du parlement c'est
un une menace pour la démocratie
et est ce que vous êtes d'accord sur les
trois points que le présent du sénat
pointe du doigt à savoir et bien le
droit d'amendement la navette
parlementaire qui serait limité et puis
la question du retour sur l'ordre du
jour partagé qui a été l'un des apports
de la réforme de docteur bien entendu
tout démocrate doit qu'on sait que le
parlement c'est l'endroit où se délibère
ce vote les lois
ça n'est pas le conseil des ministres et
au parlement pour que les lois soient
légitimes il faut qu'ils aient du temps
pour que le parlement puisse interagir
avec la société pour que les
parlementaires se finalement s'imprègne
des enjeux de la loi et puisse proposer
librement librement et pas parce qu'ils
sont dans telle ou telle partie des
propositions de modifications et en
débattre si l'exécutif considère que le
parlement est une étape de trop pour
diriger les affaires du pays
c'est une régression démocratique
lourdes est ce que le gouvernement
propose aujourd'hui est très inquiétant
pour la démocratie et en même temps
est-ce que l'on ne peut pas à comprendre
un certain nombre de mesures pour
limiter le droit d'amendement à ce qu'il
n'y a pas de plus en plus d'amendements
aujourd'hui et des amendements de plus
en plus de cavaliers législatifs fois
les cavaliers non parce que les
cavaliers conseil constitutionnel dit il
en fait son affaire derrière donc on
fait attention nous mêmes on peut les
faire et puis besoin face à la crise du
de la vie parlementaire et vous savez
parfaitement qu'entre les droits que
nous avons et les droits que nous
exerçons nous sommes très limités en
termes de droit d'amendement en termes
de prise de parole on se concentre sur
on essaie de se concentrer sur
l'essentiel et il faut bien voir que
enfin avez-vous en mémoire la dernière
fois que yeux de l'obstruction
parlementaire c'est très très rare et
d'un autre côté c'est important bah oui
non mais c'est très rare et quand c'est
de l'obstruction parlementaire
c'est pas les parlements c'est par les
parlementaires qui veulent faire de ces
parce qu'en fait ils sont sa phase avec
la société
donc réellement vouloir mettre au pas
les parlementaires les réduire couper
leurs liens avec la population c'est
vraiment inquiétant pour la démocratie
au vu de tous ces désaccords
fondamentaux entre le sénat et le
gouvernement est ce que vous pensez que
l'on puisse aboutir à un texte adopté
conforme entre les deux chambres
puisque le premier ministre a bien dit
qu'il passait par l'article 89 ans pour
c'est déjà une satisfaction je serai
j'irai c'est normal que le gouvernement
respecte la constitution mais ça fait
quelques temps déjà que le premier
président de la république ans
visage est de le faire à la de gaulle ce
que gaston monnerville avait qualifié de
forfaiture bon au moins on sait qu'ils
vont respecter l'article 89
eh bien il faudra il appartiendra à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat de
faire en sorte que cette proposition de
réforme constitutionnelle ne soit pas la
première régression depuis le début de
la vème république
mais soit aussi une progression dans
l'existence de contre-pouvoirs et de
construction d'une démocratie plus forte
et de réfléchir aussi parce qu'il n'y a
rien dans ce projet de loi sur
l'évolution de la démocratie
participative
c'était là l'un des projets d'ailleurs
du groupe socialiste a cessé de notre
centre on ne peut pas aujourd'hui
réforme et moderniser nos institutions
sans se poser la question
effectivement du rôle du parlement non
pas par l'exécutif pour qu'il soit pour
qu'ils soient meilleurs exécutants des
décisions du gouvernement
mais pour qu'il soit plus en phase avec
la société et qu'il soit le porte parole
de l'ensemble de la population et fasse
de la très vite jean yves le conte juste
serait bien le renouvellement total du
sénat en 2021 est ce que c'est là une
nouvelle ligne rouge pour le sénat et
pour vous je l'avais dit dès le départ
c'est un sénat qui renouvelle un seul
coup c'est un sénat qui perd de sa
substance parce qu'en fait il perd de sa
capacité de continuité un sénat qui est
renouvelée d'une seule manière c'est un
sénat qui perd une partie de ses
spécificités par rapport à l'âne de
sembler nationale bref c'est affaiblir
le bicamérisme on commence à l'affaiblir
et quand on commence à l'affaiblir alors
il s'excusera petit à petit mais
finalement c'est assez cohérent avec la
volonté finalement d'attaquer la
démocratie parlementaire
merci beaucoup jean yves le conte
d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci à
vous pour cette réaction effectivement
cet aspect du renouvellement total du
sénat 2021 ça fait beaucoup parler sur
ce plateau
ce n'est pas encore dans le volet
constitutionnel qui a été présenté ce
matin il y aura donc ce renouvellement
entier pour l'instant stade document moi
je n'ai pas eu entre les mains mais qui
est un document envoyé au président du
sénat l'a laissé fuiter pour essayer de
faire remonter les contestations comme
méthode on fait bien à toi j'attends
j'attends de savoir ce qu'il ya dans le
texte exactement et ce que je crois
savoir parce que je m'en suis ému aussi
j'ai appelé le cabinet du premier
ministre
tout ça est nature à être amendé il y
aura des amendements on pourrait
demander à être discuté à être négociées
on part d'une position un peu ferme
on verra ça dépendra si le sénat veut
oui ou non accepter la réforme nationale
le sénat et le sénat délibérément par
les moyens aux parano tu veux faire
opposition à la réforme
leur mort et trois sur la ligne dure
c'est clair mais est ce que ça veut dire
hervé marseille je donne la parole à
présent pierceur que certains sénateurs
qui ont été élus lors du dernier
renouvellement vont voir leur mandat
interrompt oui mais moi je sais pas
j'attends je discute que sur des textes
qui ont été présentés au conseil des
ministres on peut parler de tas de
choses à dire sur le texte
aujourd'hui qui a été présenté au
conseil des ministres et qui concernent
spécifiquement la constitution je pense
qu'il ya rien à surmontable c'est normal
qu'ils aient un dialogue
et si chacun est de bonne foi on peut on
peut trouver des solutions et moi je
vous vois pourquoi ni les uns ni les
autres ne seraient de bonne foi ne
serait pas de
de bonne foi et je préfère un parlement
on trouve des solutions et on vote
plutôt que de laisser la contestation à
la rue quand on voit soit pas trier a
cité la loi ferroviaire bon ça a été
voté à l'assemblée on voit bien que
c'est de nature à apaiser quand même les
choses même s'il ya toujours débat même
si les syndicats sont toujours sur le
sujet extrêmement sensible
je veux dire déjà l'assemblée a voté et
le premier ministre m'a dit on attend
beaucoup du débat au sénat
donc il vaut mieux des textes qu'ils
soient discutées au parlement et
j'allais dire qu'ils permettent de
trouver des solution législative plutôt
que de laisser la rue
s'énerver sur sur des sujets qui
auraient pas été discuté et on rejoint
là encore la représentation d'hier
territoriale il faut que tous et toutes
soient représentés il ya des partis avec
lequel j'ai aucune commune
mesure infinité d'affinités je veux dire
le front national les insoumis etc
mais si ces gens là arrivent à
représenter 15 ou 20 % de l'opinion
paraît normal qu'ils aient une
représentation parlementaire parce
qu'encore une fois je préfère qu'ils
puissent exprimer dans une enceinte
parlementaire que de s'exprimer à
travers des mouvements de rue
quand yasser oui moi je suis partisan
qu'on arrive à un accord avec le
gouvernement
vraiment pas ce qu'il y à une
modernisation de la constitution qui est
nécessaire et je pense que le président
de la république a eu raison de lancer
ce chantier
mais c'est alors qu'apparaît pierre
corneille car vous connaissez cette
tragédie qui s'appelle horace et les
horace et les curiaces si on nous dit
chers amis vous allez voter le texte
constitutionnel
on peut voter il y a beaucoup de choses
avec lesquelles il peut y avoir un
accord puis après il y aura la loi
organique
ah et puis in fine est de la loi
ordinaire et là vous verrez bien ce que
vous verrez je dis non non il faut qu'il
ya un accord sur le paquet parce que ça
fait un ensemble
donc moi je préconise que l'on essaie
par dialogue par une confrontation par
explications d'arriver à un accord avec
le sénat l'assemblée nationale et
l'exécutif sur les trois volets et s'il
ya un accord serait tout paquet ligne
rouge pour ça oui bien sûr pas donné de
rougemont mais pour ça il faut il faut
être ouvert au dialogue
tu sais très bien que nous le sommes et
nous le sommes nous nous sommes des
hommes et des femmes de diallo bon donc
je précise un accord mais ça suppose
qu'on ne dise pas vous avez voté le
premier texte lu on verra pour le
deuxième week-end chercheurs à pâques et
le référendum est toujours dans l'esprit
du gouvernement c'est ce qu'a dit alix
dre loubet il a gardé les sauts va
garder son on les écoute sur l'aspect
révision constitutionnelle c'est à dire
le texte que nous avons présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres
nous savons très bien qu'il n'ya pas de
référendum possible
le conseil constitutionnel a déjà eu
l'occasion enfin je veux dire il n'y a
pas de référendum possible à benicio il
y en a un possible dans le cadre de la
procédure normale de l'article 89 après
que l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
aient voté le texte dans les mêmes
termes
alors le président de la république
pourra choisir soit convoquer le congrès
soin d'appeler au référendum
mais nous sommes bien dans le cadre de
la procédure normale de révision
constitutionnelle il en va différemment
sur les deux autres textes la loi
ordinaire et la loi organique ou là la
question pourrait se poser elle n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour à l'heure actuelle
sur intel va est ce que le gouvernement
va être obligé de passer par un
référendum en est ce qu'il peut y avoir
un accord on entendu et l'optimisme de
se rendre sur place à l'aboutissement de
ces réformes
je pense que depuis depuis le congrès de
versailles
il ya toujours eu un dialogue qui a été
instaurée entre le sénat l'assemblée
nationale présentent la république extra
donc aujourd'hui on est dans la tente
d'un accord et bien évidemment si on
peut y arriver on le fera après je
rejoins ce qui est dit jean pierre sueur
effectivement on a un premier paquet qui
était présenté aujourd'hui en conseil
des ministres les deux os de loi a
priori vont arriver le 23 mai et c'est
clairement un accord sur la totalité que
l'on veut maintenant il ya des certaines
mesures qui arrive du jour au lendemain
on sait pas comment vous avez parlé de
la date de septembre 2021
là dessus il faudra bien évidemment que
le gouvernement entende ce que les
parlementaires auront à dire parce que
la plupart on a reçu effectivement sa
fuite et on a reçu les textes on se dit
voilà il faut il faut qu'on ait ce
dialogue
bien évidemment le travail parlementaire
va être là on aura les amendements et on
espère qu'on sera écoutée et qu'on aura
on ira pas au référendum mais qu'on
aille un travail dans le collectif qui
aboutit soultz intel va françois patriat
disais au début de ce débat
parler de duplicité en parlant d'eux
hier larcher on le dit filmant
finalement écartelé entre sa double
casquette d'un côté président du sénat
il veut aboutir un compromis mais il
fait aussi partie du comité stratégique
de votre parti et à l'est républicain
c'est le sentiment vous avez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui gérard larcher et
président du
l'un est président des territoires donc
nous on a intérêt tous autour de la
table a trouvé une réforme qui soit
équilibrée où tout le monde trouve son
compte
est-ce qu'il est suffisamment opposé au
chef de l'état ça lui a été reprochée en
interne tête là dessus je vais pas je
passe je passe te tuer on a on est
aujourd'hui dans des discussions le
texte final surfant sur les trois textes
finaux on n'a pas été votée qu'est-ce
qu'est ce qu'il en sera je pense que
aujourd'hui on est dans le on est dans
le travail parlementaire après on verra
bien au niveau du parti comment les
choses comment les choses ont évolué
mais je pense que là on va dans le enfin
gérard larcher fait les choses en bonne
intelligence c'est à dire travailler
avec l'ensemble des parties et après on
verra si les lignes rouges encore une
fois quand les deux autres textes seront
présentés on verra où on ira si on
arrive à trouver un consensus
qu'ils fassent écho au niveau du sénat
et aussi au niveau du parti des
républicains
ce sera parfait mais j'espère qu'on ira
dans ce sens là et recueillera dans le
main event
benjamin morel sur l'aspect
renouvellement du sénat en 2021 et il
faudra passer par une modification du
calendrier des élections sénatoriales il
faut modifier la constitution c'est à
dire que là est le gros problème du
gouvernement sur cette question
en fait tous les toutes les toutes les
menaces que le gouvernement peut faire
peser sur le sénat où toutes les
questions qui
qui peuvent gêner les sénateurs en fait
elles relèvent principalement de la
constitution cette question du
renouvellement total en 2021 elle pose
question allées du domaine
constitutionnel parce que si les pâtes
domaine constitutionnel c'est une forme
de dissolution donc là on rentre dans
quelque chose qui normalement est
absolument inconstitutionnelle et même
dangereux donc il faut un accord du
sénat il faut que ça passe par des
dispositions transitoires dans la
constitution
sur la question du mode d'élection des
sénateurs le département circonscription
d'élection c'est la jurisprudence du
conseil 86 2008
c'est acté dans la constitution il faut
l'accord du sénat pour le modifier
sur la question du corps elect du
collège électoral du sénat
les marges de manoeuvre sont en fait
extrêmement restreinte il faut l'accord
du sénat pour modifier c'est du domaine
constitutionnel sur la question de du
suffrage universel indirect là
évidemment c'est dans la constitution il
faut l'accord du sénat pour le modifier
donc le rapport de force il est là en
fait pourquoi un paquet et bien parce
qu'en fait pour que le sénat donne son
aval cela il faut sur les lois sur la
les réformes constitutionnelles
il veut avoir l'oeil sur la loi
organique et sur la loi ordinaire et
face à ça
le gouvernement est bien en fait n'a pas
vraiment de possibilité de peser sur le
sénat sur ce qui fait l'essentiel de
cette institution aujourd'hui à part sur
le nombre de ses membres
on va continuer à l'analyse en quatre
tours dans un amour à sion restait avec
no merci à vous aux empires soeur merci
on a sur intel va merci à françois
patriat on va retrouver est en train de
nuit pour une nouvelle réaction vous
êtes avec le sénateur communiste du val
de marne pascal à savoir des lycées
tabou pascal savoldelli comment
interprétez vous le projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui a été présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres est ce
que il ya une volonté de faire régresser
les droits du parlement est ce que vous
y voyez peut-être aussi une tentation
autoritaire de la part d' emmanuel
macron là où a été tendu la perche parce
que avec tout le respect que je dois au
président de la république je trouve que
cette réforme est le fait du roi il est
inédit dans la vème république qu'on ait
une telle réduction du droit
parlementaire et donc je pense qu'on est
dans une réforme
qui montrent qu'on a un président de la
république un exécutif qui est dans une
moment de défiance vis-à-vis des
parlementaires des vis-à-vis des
citoyens
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
l'exécutif vise à plus d'efficacité 1
c'était les arguments qu'on a pu
entendre ce matin notamment de la bouche
de la garde des sceaux notamment pour à
propos de la limitation du drame en
d'amendements de la limitation de la
navette parlementaire encore de ce
retour sur l'ordre du jour partagé
écoutez je crois ce qu'il faut il faut
assumer il faut que l'exécutif national
assume ses termes de quelle efficacité
on parle est ce qu'on parle de
l'efficacité public
ou est ce qu'on parle du notre
efficacité moi je trouve que cette
réforme telle qu'elle nous est présenté
à ce jour est une réforme qui qui qui
vient de l'exigence de la finance
c'est à dire qu'en gros le pouvoir
législatif le parlement
donc le travail à l'assemblée nationale
comme le travail au sénat devient un
obstacle pour libéraliser marchandises l
ensemble des activités humaines et à
partir de là il faut en restreindre les
possibilités d'action les possibilités
de contrôle et il ya un autre aspect
c'est un une majorité un président qui
veut délégitimer les oppositions c'est
très très très grave
c'est très très grave est-ce que vous
avez conscience qu'en même temps le
gouvernement par sa communication
notamment un peu commune qui certains
aspects de la réforme comme la réduction
du nombre de parlementaires pour faire
apparaître l'opposition du sénat comme
très impopulaire écoutez souvent on fait
des comparaisons avec l'europe
je vous prends à témoin vérifier il n'y
a pas plus de parlementaires en france
qui est dans tous les autres pays à
démographie en fonction de la
démographie ne paie donc ya pas plus de
parlementaires en france il ya pas trop
parlementaire ce n'est pas la question
d'abord deuxièmement la conf abric la
loi est là on va vers à la fois une
réforme si j'ai bien compris de la
constitution mais aussi avec une loi
organique et une loi ordinaire
vous imaginez quel va être le rapport du
parlementaire qu'est sénateur ou
sénatrice vis-à-vis de quatre cent mille
habitants ou d'un député ou d'une
députée vis-à-vis de 240 mille habitants
l'ashram deux reprises par des gallois
dès qu'il faut faire la loi avec les
citoyens vont faire la loi avec les
chambres consulaires faut faire la loi
avec les organismes
dick a offert la loi avec la vie
associative donc moi je voilà ce que je
pense c'est que d'abord on devrait
ouvrir ce débat par un grand débat
public
il n'y a pas une urgence il n'y a pas
une priorité absolue prenons quelques
mois ouvrons un débat public dans tout
le pays après ouvrons le débat
parlementaire et vous verrez que les
citoyens des parlementaires ont des
propositions des idées un tout dernier
point pascal savoldelli quelle est votre
réaction à cette possibilité de
renouvellement intégral du sénat en 2021
ça aussi ça serait dans les cartons de
l'exécutif on l'a entendu cela pose déjà
des problèmes constitutionnels quelles
sont les intentions pour vous de
l'exécutif terre cela il ya ce que ça
posait pour des questions
constitutionnelles de raccourcir les
mandats écoutez franchement je n'ose pas
le penser mais on a un problème de la
vème république c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on a un président qui est élu grâce à
la présence du front national au
deuxième tour
et à partir de là il veut manipuler les
citoyens et les parlementaires
en faisant cette petite opération avec
le renouvellement complet en 2021 bien
merci beaucoup pascal savoldelli d'avoir
répondu à ma question merci j'ai eu qu'à
cette édition spéciale de senna 360
consacré à cette réforme des
institutions le premier volet
constitutionnel a été présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres gérard larcher
a répondu cet après midi lors d'une
conférence de presse je vous propose de
réécouter le président et cela pour
résumer on conditionne le droit
d'amendement
on vide son utilité la navette
parlementaire on préempte l'ordre du
jour je vois pas comment on peut nous
expliquer que ces dispositions ne vont
pas dans le sens de l'affaiblissement du
parlement bicaméral et de leur
concentration du pouvoir par l'exécutif
nous invite à revoir la dernière
séquence de l'examen du projet de loi
dit l'immigration débattu à l'assemblée
nationale pas un seul amendement de
l'opposition repris et exclusion du
groupe majoritaire du seul député qui a
osé voter contre le texte
ça promet de nouveaux invités nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau esther benbassa
bonjour merci d'être avec nous cette
sénatrice écologiste est rattachée au
groupe communiste
c'est la triste de paris membre de la
commission des lois également avec nos
clubs manu rées bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation avec le
président du groupe les indépendants
république et territoires ici au sénat
vous êtes par ailleurs et bien sénateur
de l'allier comment avez vous accueilli
est question pour vous claude malhuret
cette réforme des institutions dont je
disais le premier volet a été présenté
ce matin en conseil des ministres il y
avait une seule chose de nouveau ce
matin une seule chose nouvelle ce matin
juste où tout le reste tout ce qui a été
présenté ça fait déjà quelques semaines
que qu'on le connaît la seule chose
nouvelle c'est le mode d'élection c'est
la surprise de septembre 2021 avec un
mode d'élection globale et non plus une
élection partielle du sénat donc voilà
le problème qui commence à se poser sur
le reste du texte notamment sur la
fabrique de la loi puisqu'on vient
beaucoup d'en parler ici ça pose
problème certains y voient un
affaiblissement du parlement oui les
propositions qui sont faites sont un
recul par rapport à la réforme de 2008
2008 avait été accueillie très
favorablement parce que c'était une
avancée dans cette cinquième république
très déséquilibrée entre l'exécutif et
législatives c'était une avancée pour
les parlementaires pour les parlements
et la fixation notamment de l'ordre du
jour partagé était une avancée assez
considérable suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que
les parlementaires sont soit saisie
autant qu'ils auraient pu le faire mais
en tout cas il en avait la possibilité
on revient manifestement là dessus avec
un ordre du jour qui aujourd'hui avec ce
qui est mis dedans serait probablement à
80 90 % de nature gouvernementales et
plus de nature partager c'est bien
entendu un recul mais moi je vais vous
dire une chose c'est lé parlement qui va
décider le gouvernement brewers ça
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas lui qui
décide c'est l'assemblée nationale et
c'est le sénat et c'est donc à eux de se
montrer responsable il me paraît pas
pensable qu'on accepte un certain nombre
de choses et on va donc faire des
contre-propositions et d'ailleurs je
suis assez je pense que ça peut le
dialogue dont on a parlé j'ai écouté
tout à l'heure le début de votre
émission je pense que ce dialogue projet
mais moi je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent qu'il peut déboucher
mais avant tout c'est l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat qui en sont à 6
accepte que l'ordre du jour ne leur
échappe s'il accepte que le droit
d'amendement en partie leur échappe
après tout s'ils se montrent godillots
qu'il le fasse mais c'est nous les
responsables et par conséquent c'est à
nous de faire cette réforme dans un
dialogue avec le gouvernement mais en
définitive c'est notre responsabilité
star band bassin on est face à un
président pressé qui veut faire adopter
rapidement ces réformes face à un
parlement
jugé trop lent est ce que cette réforme
va permettre de rééquilibrer les choses
écoutez c'est pas la vitesse comme
mesures la démocratie me semble-t-il
il ya quelques points dans
en ce ce texte dans ce projet de loi qui
fait que les quais loulou enfin je peux
dire que je suis pour juba le coup la
diminution du nombre de membres du
conseil économique social et
environnemental la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature la
suppression de la cour ce sont des
points qui font briller la suppression
du prêt vitale ont justement des points
qui posent problème avait justement sur
cette fabrique de la loi oui mais moi je
crois dans cette fabrique de la loi pour
la dcc c'est non seulement utile mais
primordial pour le fonctionnement de la
démocratie
pour une fois ces enjeux partagés en
général les idées de monsieur larcher
là je suis d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
parce qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
comme ça entrait dans le vif et donné
des armes un président pressé et qui
auraient préféré qu'on n'existe pas et
cela dans un en se servant de
l'impopularité
des élus auprès de la population donc
c'est une machine à cliver donc là il
pense qu'il peut faire passer pas mal de
choses parce que et nous soufflant du
désamour de du peuple à notre égard mais
enfin c'est je trouve à ce qu'a dit
monsieur malheureux justement est
d'accord que de malleray évoquer cette
question du partage l'ordre du jour 1
sadate et bien de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la
tentation à demandera un peu sur les
semaine d'initiative parlementaire
là aussi je vous propose de réécouter
les genres larcher le troisième sujet
concerne l'ordre du jour article 8 du
projet de loi comme le gouvernement je
pense qu'il faut examiner les problèmes
que soulève l'organisation de l'ordre du
jour
nous y sommes ouverts dans votre
ailleurs débattues et françois de rugy
avons proposé des pistes pour une
meilleure organisation mais pas en
sacrifiant le principe de l'ordre du
jour partagé qui est d'ailleurs un
acquis majeur d'une révision 2008 le
projet de loi crée une nouvelle super
priorité gouvernementale est en fait
quand on additionne l'ensemble des
priorités c'est super priorité ça fait
90% des textes qui relève de la super
priorité
jean pierre serre ça c'est du jour
partagé puisque ça pas toujours bien
fonctionné le rappeler à l'instant
claude malhuret
l'idée ce serait une régression
formidable par rapport à 2008
moi j'ai connu il ya longtemps un
parlement où la totalité de l'ordre du
jour était fixé par le gouvernement
c'était insupportable c'est à dire
pratiquement unique dans les pays
démocratiques et on a pu obtenir un jour
deux jours dans le mois
et puis dans la révision de 2008 il y a
quinze jours pour les projets de loi
venant du gouvernement
huit jours pour les propositions
venant du parlement et huit jours pour
le contrôle exercé par le parlement là
on nous dit à tout moment à tout moment
dès lors que le gouvernement trouvera
qu'un texte est important il pourra le
caser dans le temps réservée à
l'initiative parlementaire tant que
c'est absolument insupportable
on ne pourra pas accepter cela on ne
peut pas vraiment pas parce que tout le
monde voit bien que notre démocratie
fonctionne bien sûr tous et sur ses deux
pieds ou trois pieds montesquieu et il
faut absolument que le parlement au
contraire voix moi je suis partisan
voyez que sur un mois il y ait deux
tiers des jours à l'initiative du
gouvernement et un tiers pour les
propositions là parce que le contrôle
tentation tentative du gouvernement de
présenter ce temps parlementaire cet
ordre du jour
oui à l'évidence il ya je pas revenir
sur l'ensemble des mesures qui ont été
discutés ici et qui porte atteinte aux
droits du parlement mais au-delà de ça
je vais dire on est aussi en train
parlementaires des élus politiques c'est
pas un gros mot que de le dire non et
dire le le président la majorité y
veulent en venir où ils veulent en venir
ou parce que on peut discuter de telle
et telle mesure en disant on va soupeser
le problème des amendements de l'ordre
du jour parlementaire etc etc
c'est un tout on l'a dit et parce qu'il
est là dedans il ya la loi organique
avec le nombre de parlementaires la
représentation des territoires puis les
modes de scrutin
brandy
monsieur morel l'a dit tout à l'heure un
peu de façon menaçante même si c'est
avec un sabre de bois on veut en venir
ou où il ya une volonté de dialogue de
part et d'autre et moi encore une fois
je pense que pour quoi on mettrait en
doute la volonté de dialogue du
gouvernement et la volonté de dialogue
du sénat et puis il ya des voies de
passage parce que là dedans on peut
discuter et trouver des solutions
oui en a pas et à ce moment là on veut
en venir où ça le sujet parce que le
reste c'est technique
ma foi dont pour on pourra toujours
ergoter sur telle ou telle chose le
problème c'est où on va revenir je
voulais ajouter également tout en étant
d'accord avec vous ça m'arrive pas
souvent vous voyez un sur ce sujet on
est à peu près d'accord cesser les
dérives quand même de la vème république
là on est arrivé au summum un président
qui voudrait prendre
tout en main y compris n'est ce pas
comme vous l'avait dit lors du jour du
sénat et voilà depuis des années nous
les écologistes
on dit qu'il faut passer à la 6ème
république là on est vraiment dans le la
perversité de la vème république que le
président on voudrait encore renforcé
son pouvoir et la vème république lui
autorise le l'autorisent à le faire oui
moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit que ça
vienne du président paradoxalement parce
que d'abord ça n'était pas dense et ces
choses qui viennent d'être ajoutées ce
n'était pas dans sa campagne électorale
il y avait des choses qui j'ai
l'impression que ça vient de la majorité
de l'énorme majorité république en
marche société civile qui est dans la
plus grande partie n'avait jamais mis
les pieds au parlement qui était chef
d'entreprise professions libérales et
cetera qui arrivent et qui sait et qui
découvre que parlement on parle grandes
découvertes mais étymologiquement le
parlement s'est fait pour parler
beaucoup d'entre eux voient ça et se dit
c'est pas de répit kassav à pavie à
trouver amendements et c'était pas le
conseil d'administration voit là et il
ya cette pression pour gagner pour lire
faut que ça aille plus vite
mais comme la pression vient aussi
l'opinion publique et des français qui
attendent des récents se disent sache
exactement combien de temps on prend
pour mettre pour faire une loi et c'est
d'autant plus que comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure c'est souvent les décrets
met souvent beaucoup plus de temps que
le parlement est ce qu est ce qui est
étonnant c'est que les mêmes qui disent
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup trop de lois
et beaucoup de gens sont d'accord là
dessus on a souvent d'accord là-dessus
journal officiel quinze mille pages en
81 25 mille pages aujourd'hui donc on
est une parlement une démocratie qui
fait trop de lois et qu'il ne s'applique
pas mais on nous propose c'est paradoxal
de d'accélérer le travail parlementaire
au détriment des droits du parlement
à quoi ça va aboutir à faire encore plus
de loi puisque si on dégage du temps
c'est bien entendu par hbo pour pouvoir
en proposer d'autres dans un pays où on
est où c'est une plaie une vraie plaie
de tout faire passer par la loi et
ensuite de ne pas les appliquer donc je
trouve que c'est très paradoxal j'ai
l'impression que la majorité est en
train de découvrir ça j'espère que cette
majorité petit à petit va découvrir que
le parlement s'est fait pour parler que
les lois c'est fait pour être discuté
longuement et que quand ça ne veut pas
ça n'est pas discuté longuement que ce
n'est pas du temps perdu de lui discuté
longuement j'ai l'impression que cette
majorité à l'assemblée nationale ne l'a
pas encore compris
je crois que françois de rugy le
président de l'association l'a compris
et qu'il est en train de discuter avec
gérard larcher avec filet edouard
philippe et puis emmanuel manqueront
j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir
mais encore une fois j'ai l'impression
que ça ne vient pas tellement du
président qu'il est en train d'être
débordés par des gens qui croient bien
faire mais qu'ils ne s'aperçoivent pas
qu'ils vont se tirer une balle dans le
pied
benjamin moret l'on vient d'entendre les
arguments des différentes politiques
ce que dit claude malhuret très
inquiétants parce que si c'est la
majorité en effet la république en
marche qui pousse à la dureté
ça veut dire qu'il pourra pas y avoir
d'accord entre le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale
or la seule chance de cette réforme qui
est quand même inacceptable en l'état
pour les sénateurs et pour de façon
générale tous les parlementaires
d'opposition pour d'autres députés c'est
une alliance au dessus de la tête du
gouvernement
entre les députés éventuellement avec
comme têtes d'affiché françois de rugy
et les sénateurs pour améliorer les
droits du parlement
or là très clairement et ben ça va pas
dans ce sens c'est à dire que ce projet
de loi cadier gérard larcher aujourd'hui
grosso modo il a dit je suis là pour
discuter je veux bien discuter mais tout
ce qu'il ya sur le parlement ça ne me
plaît pas et donc d'une certaine façon
le veto il est sur l'ensemble des choses
qui sont avancés sur le parlement et qui
réduisent les droits du parlement
donc est ce que cette réforme peut
aboutir mais elle n'en prend pas
forcément chemin ne serait ce que parce
que il ya eu des comités de travail il
ya eu des discussions que le
gouvernement n'en a pas tenu compte et
que donc il ya peut-être un une
confiance qui s'est rompu et 2 en tout
cas il ya un travail de dialogue qui n'a
pas réellement commencé en tout cas qui
n'a pas porté ses fruits dans les arts
merci merci benjamin morel pour votre
analyse merci hervé marseille merci jean
bien sûr merci à vous et sert ben bassaw
merci à claude malhuret
la discussion et l'analyse continue sur
cette réforme des institutions avec
l'émission de rebecca fitoussi on va
plus loin c'est à 18h30 bonne suite des
programmes sur public sénat
[Musique]